darüber sprechen wir mit daniel caspary
ist vorsitzender der cdu/csu-gruppe im
europaparlament und mitglied des
präsidiums der cdu deutschland guten tag
herr caspar ich grüße sie herr caspar
wieder ein gespräch gestern nacht
zwischen den beiden kontrahenten laschet
und söder das ohne ergebnis zu ende ging
wie lange kann sich die union diese
ungeklärte kanzlerkandidatenfrage noch
leisten
der vorderste am besten wäre gewesen
diese kandidaten frage wer schon seit
einigen tagen erledigt werden einen
gemeinsamen kandidaten und die
mitglieder könnten sich hinter diesen
kandidaten zu versammeln was meine
überzeugung übrigens bereichen
kandidaten der fall
das hat die situation ist ja leider
nicht eingetreten und jetzt zeichnet
sich ab je länger eine entscheidung
dauert desto mehr schwindet die
zustimmung für armin laschet gestern
abend sprachen sich die
landesvorsitzenden der jungen union mit
großer mehrheit für den markus söder den
kontrahenten aus letzte woche haben wir
gesehen dass ministerpräsidenten insider
lager gewechselt sind kreisverbände was
geht in ihnen vor oder was ging in ihnen
gestern abend vor wenn sie diese
nachrichtenlage verfolgen
das alter ist es wenig verwundert dass
einige gremien ihre boten mir jetzt
einholen wir hatten
letzten montag die sitzung von
bundespräsidium und bundesvorstand ich
selbst war für mich selbstverständlich
in den tagen wochen und monaten vorher
umgehört wie ist die stimmung in der
partei wenn sie beispielsweise boden
nehmen die sie ja und immer ganz so
deutlich wie sich schau an ausschauen
nehmen sie sich beispielsweise das votum
der jung-millionär da es nach
landesverbänden 14 zu 4
auf der anderen seite wenn sie danach
mitgliedern geben wieviel mitglieder
stehen denn in den landesverbänden der
zis plötzlich gar nicht mehr so deutlich
aus dann sieht es auf 45 zu 55 des
friedens aber alles gar nicht weiter
fort aus sondern er klar ist ich habe
den eindruck auf der einen seite haben
wir die stimmung bei vielen mitgliedern
die ist doch offensichtlich dass sie ja
auch in vielen umfragen und auf der
anderen seite haben wir dafür gewählte
führungsgremien die führungsgremien
haben wir nicht einfach aus dem nichts
heraus am montag lässt
stimmungsbilder abgegeben sondern aus
guten gründen die wir sicherlich auch
aus wahlkampf strategischen gründen und
anderen gründen nicht öffentlich
darlegen können ich habe schon den
eindruck bei aller präferenz vieler
vieler mitglieder immer mehr mitglieder
machen sich auch gedanken was treibt zum
beispiel jemanden wie wolfgang schäuble
oder friedrich merz um die er beim
bundesparteitag bei der frage um den
bundesvorsitz ganz andere vorstellungen
hatten dass sie so vehement für armin
laschet antreten also ich habe schon den
eindruck die mitgliederschaft ist hier
ein gewisser weise zerrissen und wir
brauchen
der wunsch ist doch klar wir brauchen
einen gemeinsamen kandidaten wenn wir
gemeinsam und ist als wahlgewinner
also sie sprechen diese diskrepanz ist
ein konflikt zwischen der
mitgliederschaft zwischen der basis und
den spitzengremien der partei an
präsidium und parteivorstand haben sie
jetzt ganz gesagt sie haben sich letzte
woche für armin laschet ausgesprochen
und bislang galt doch das prinzip dass
parteiendemokratie repräsentiert wird
durch die gewählten gremien einer partei
gilt das jetzt nicht mehr
ja genau das ist mit einer frage des
systems 2000 wie wollen wir uns als
christdemokraten in deutschland
weiterentwickeln und das sind umfragen
sicherlich ein wichtiges mittel aber ich
sage ihnen auch ganz offen dass umfragen
eben nicht grundlage für alle
entscheidend sein können erkennt man
daran nach umfragen hätten wir im
november uns diese angela merkel
ausgesprochen im dezember für friedrich
merz im januar für jetzt sparen jetzt im
april für markus söder und dann
vielleicht im september doch für armin
laschet oder wenn wir nach umfragen
gegangen wären dann hätte unsere
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
durchschnitt einmal im quartal und
helmut kohl im zweifel ein mal in der
woche zurücktreten müssen
und ganz wichtig bei inhaltlichen frage
stellen verstellungen wenn wir immer
nach umfragen gegangen wären gerade bei
europäischen themen die ich ein
schwerpunkt betreue er dann hätten wir
uns bei der wirtschafts und finanzkrise
vor zehn jahren oder bei der migrations
krise vor fünf jahren oder auch jetzt
bei der korona krise vielleicht anders
verhalten und deswegen ist doch eben die
stärke der repräsentativen demokratie
dass wir parteien haben in einer breiten
basis
die natürlich in den willensbildung
meinungsbildungsprozess eingebunden ist
und dass wir aber auch eine basis haben
die eben dann führungswechsel
weiten welt die sich dann auch eben
gewählt sind damit sie verantwortung
übernehmen und ich wünsche mir dass wir
hier nicht mit dem bade ausschütten und
einfach unser system der repräsentativen
demokratie dann komplett abschaffen es
war immer eine stärke der union dass wir
genau das ist was der kurzer zwischen
gehen enden jetzt haben sie zweimal die
kanzlerin angesprochen angela merkel
hält sich bislang zurück in der
diskussion ist dass die richtige das
richtige verhalten oder hätten sie
erwartet von ihr sie war selbst auch
einmal cdu-parteivorsitzende dass sie
sich doch irgendwie hinter ihren neuen
cdu parteivorsitzenden stellt die
gedankliche starken bundeskanzlerin und
sie macht es aus meiner sicht wichtig
wir sollten doch den findungsprozess
eines neuen kleinen daten nicht dadurch
belastet dass hier die bundeskanzlerin
sich einig wissen sie wir hatten vor
einigen wochen und monaten quasi die
sorge vieler mitglieder und vieler
beobachter in der öffentlichkeit mischt
sich angela merkel einstecken wahrheit
angela merkel hinter der kandidatur von
armin laschet als bundesvorsitzender
jetzt heißt wird sich angela merkels
schraube es ist auch nicht in ordnung
das sehen sie auch wieder die schnelle
öffentliche meinung und öffentliche
stimmung kippen
und deshalb ist mir immer wichtig ich
bin in die cdu eingetreten aufgrund von
grundüberzeugungen von wertefragen so
ein charakter fragen
das spielt alles eine rolle in diesen
tagen und da wünsche ich mir auch
manchmal etwas manches mitglied es sich
gerne äußern über seine vorlieben aber
wir sollten bitte gut miteinander
sprechen denn teilweise es ist wirklich
abwegig welche attribute hier überall
asche oder markus söder vergangenen
tagen gewählt werden das sind beides
zwei prima calle ich kenne beide aus der
zusammenarbeit wie werden beide in der
lage deutschland zu führen genauso wie
sie in der lage sind ja bundesland zu
führen was mir richtig weh tut er ist
wie hier manche übereinander kaspar
jetzt haben wir aber dieses dilemma das
so miteinander umgegangen wird wie es
gerade wird und jetzt wollen wir nach
vorne schauen was wäre denn jetzt eine
lösung so dass unterstützer die haben
vorschläge gemacht am wochenende
entweder eine abstimmung in der fraktion
am dienstag oder eine einbeziehung der
kreisvorsitzenden beider unionsparteien
ist das für sie ein gangbarer weg
welchen würden sie präferieren
als allererstes
der gangbare weg dass wir nicht im spiel
die spielregeln ändern so was geht immer
schief und spannend ist ja auch dass die
vorschläge dann immer so kommen die man
gerade mehrheiten einschätzt kleist die
bundestagsfraktion sollte hier nicht
entscheiden sondern wir haben die
situation dass die beiden parteien
entscheiden müssen und die beiden
parteien werden eben repräsentiert durch
ihre vorstände und das zweite was mir
überhaupt nicht gefällt es diese lesart
da gibt es immer nur ein gremium in dem
cdu und csu gemeinsam arbeiten wie sind
diese sprechen im moment mit dem
vorsitzenden der cdu csu gruppe im
europäischen parlament ist zum beispiel
ein zweites gremium dann übrigens die
frage werde in deutschland bundeskanzler
wird welche europapolitische und welche
generelle politische ausrichtung ge
haben ist für ganz europa unserer
europapolitik relevanten sagen wir
wollen auch sprechen und dann merken sie
spielregeln werden dem spiel zu ändern
das ist eine sache der parteien und
jetzt bei anderen europa ist ein gutes
stichwort was löst ein markus söder in
europa aus er und die csu haben ja vor
gar nicht allzu langer zeit viktor orban
empfangen ja auch da sind sie im kern
armin laschet hat europa politik auch
nicht durch seine regionale herkunft in
die wiege gelegt bekommen
markus söder hat auch gelernt als
bayerischer ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten kandidat dass man in
europa keine wahlen gewinnt und jetzt
ist mir egal ob jemand euro projekt
eingestellt ist weil er das immer schon
war oder weil er aus fehlern gelernt hat
ich wünsche mir vor allem aber das biete
der lerneffekt erhalten bleibt und ich
habe in diesen tagen manchmal den
eindruck dass leider zu viele bei uns in
der union verlernt haben dass wir schon
mal vor fünf jahren bei der migrations
krise einen breiten riss durch die union
achten dass wir uns damals aus guten
hunden geschworen haben einen solchen
streit darf es nie wieder geben
ich fühle mich leider und es ist auch
die rückmeldung die ich von vielen
mitgliedern bekomme zurückversetzt in
dieser zeit und deshalb wünsche ich mir
dass die beiden jetzt wirklich schnell
eine lösung finden denn eine überschrift
gilt immer und das merke ich bei fast
allen mitgliedern in vielen gesprächen
jetzt gerade auch wieder über das
wochenende ist kein wochenende war die
allermeisten mitglieder sagen jetzt
findet bietet eine entscheidung und wir
trauern beiden zu dass die bundeskanzlei
für deutschland wären wir wollen uns
dann auch im wahlkampf hielt beide
stellen unabhängig von unserer
persönlichen presse ja und wir werden
sehen vielleicht fällt die entscheidung
ja auch schon morgen ich sagt herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch daniel caspary
vorsitzender der cdu/csu-gruppe im
europaparlament und mitglied des
präsidiums der cdu deutschland vielen
dank für das gespräch